Are you,
somebody told me you were doing,
are we saying that you're going
to do your next one independent,
you're going to do it independent?
Um, no, I don't know how
I'm going to do it. I'm,
I'm exploring all like the options
and all of that. I'm, I'm trying,
I was trying to figure out
a way to, uh, you know,
cause there's just a ton of specials out
there was just trying to figure out a
way. But I mean, you know, when
was the last time you filmed?
Uh, October, 2016. So, um, um, do,
um, do, um, but it's like, am I do, I
dunno. I Dunno. I don't, I don't, uh,
it's, it's what it is, is the special has
changed since you and I started. Yeah.
We're a special was special. Now what
it is is it's just kind of an, uh,
an hour long advertisement letting people
know that you're still out there and
it's like this just doesn't
it, it documents your stuff
though. Yeah, it does.
But there's just such a sheer amount of
stuff to see, to have like
an impact the way, like,
I was trying to think maybe the last
one that really was just like, whoa.
And I would say would be like maybe
Dave Chappelle killing them softly.
Certainly Chris rock bring the pain
where it was just like, you know,
I'm not saying there weren't ones
that like, like people talked about,
but like just that thing where like,
do you remember when we were kids it was
just like, you know, Friday, Hey man,
see you on Monday.
And then somehow on Monday everybody
saw delirious or everybody saw dice or
everybody saw Sam Kinison on, on the,
um, the, uh, the danger field thing.
And it was just like no one was
talking about it. And then just like,
there was only so many channels and that
thing just caught enough people's eye
and you came to school Monday and everyone
was just talking about it. Like, um,
okay,
you know, I'm, I'm still getting
fucking tweets from people saying, Hey,
I finally got around to
watching breaking bad,
you know what I mean? Or I was talking
about the wire one time, they were like,
dude, you, you could've
said, spoiler alert.
It's like that fucking went
off the air and like 2006,
like how much time do I have to give
you to watch it? You know. So, um,
I still haven't seen the wire due.
My Buddy, he, his uh, his son,
the number one thing that he, he,
he watches is he on his phone?
He's watching one of these guys
that gets paid to play video games.
He watches this guy on his phone play
video games. Everybody does that. Okay.
So for common. Yes. So now
that's another thing to watch.
Forget about online porn and fucking me
watching Eric, the car guy and all that.
Trying to,
trying to like find like where you can
like drop the pamphlets of your career
basically to be like, hey man,
I'm still around. I think, I think
there's definitely more
content now than ever before.
But for in terms of like the
amount of standup that's available,
does it never been more great
standup available to watch? Yeah,
I can think about how many specials
there are now. I mean, it's fun.
It's fucking crazy. Yeah, really it
is. Um, it's, yeah, so
they're not really specials,
they're not specialists.
They're not special because,
because it used to be special,
used to be the top comics.
Now arguably it was basically
the top white male comics.
So the fact that they fixed
that is a great thing. But now
though, I mean, Chris Rock, Dave
Chappelle, Damon Wayans, yes.
There was a lot of laws.
There was a lot of white guys.
There was a lot of white guys with a lot,
a lot of great buckeyes too. And really,
yeah,
the real problem was women. There
wasn't very many women. Yeah. Women like
three Asians,
there's a Paches this other people
out there doing standup specials.
There's gotta be anyways.
But what I'm saying was,
but it was the best of the best,
where now it's just everybody.
It's everybody. Right, right.
So like, I remember when,
I remember when it was changing
while I was doing a club and, uh,
the feature act was complaining that
he didn't get a half hour special.
On one of these networks and I'm thinking
like you're a feature act and like
what do you,
what are you going to do?
You're going to do your whole act and
you're still a feature and you want to
document that. And it's just like, um,
they used to give out half hour specials
when I started out and it was to like
guys who'd been on the road for like 15
years and they will pick up from there
headlining hour. Uh, they
will take an half of that,
like the best bits from an hour and then,
you know,
and that's somehow through time just
became a feature going up and doing his
whole act.
Well, Netflix is doing that now.
They have the degenerate special.
They have a big J did one. Joey Diaz
did. Juan Christina Palicki did one.
Um,
I'm not saying it's bad, I'm just
saying it's changed so because it's,
it's even changed since.
Um,
my last special that I put out my last
advertisement that I put out a hour along
advertising. Um, so you
just try to figure out,
cause everything's just fucking changing
so fast. You just trying to navigate,
like where can I put this in all of this,
right.
That it's going to blink enough that
someone's going to stare at it and maybe
like watch the thing. I just noticed
your fucking lights with the sky.
That's pretty cool.
Pretty cool, right? Yes.
What's the company that makes those octo
lights shout out to octo lights? Yeah.
Um,
Gaffigan did an interesting thing.
He decided not to put his newest one
on Netflix. He puts it on everything.
It's on Hulu and Amazon.
You can get it on iTunes but not Netflix.
He's a smart guy. Well he just
took a chance, I guess, you know,
just decided to see what happens if
you just make it available everywhere
instead. Yeah, I'd like to talk to
him, see how successful that was.
Yeah. I love, because I'm
still working out my straight,
I'll talk to you off air about it cause
I don't want, cause it fucks with my,
I get it ability to make something happen.
So I'll,
I'll tell you what my idea
was. Um, but that got nixed.
I've thought about that,
doing it and just put it right on youtube.
I've thought about doing that before.
He's not paid for it. Just shoving it
right on youtube. Just see what happens.
Yeah. And Youtube. Yeah, yeah. Just paying
for it and just sticking it out there.
Because if it is an advertisement was
the best way to get it out there. Well,
the best way would just be
to put it on Youtube. Right.
And then to segment it into like little
chunks so that people could digest it.
And yet people wind up doing that.
I don't think Netflix takes them down.
I think when you have a bits up
that like from specials that,
that go up on Netflix,
I think Netflix just let them stay up.
Just depends on what your,
uh,
what your contract is because
you can work that in. Um,
we did a special with Paul Versey
all things calming network.
We did a special with him,
which was, did phenomenal,
like broke all their
online streaming, uh, um,
records and it was great because he
was a guy that they don't really give
special tools. Right. Right. Now, you
know, who do you do the special for?
A comedy central. Oh, and uh,
so the streaming version was
really successful. Yeah. I
mean he, he, he did well on,
well now trying to get people to
actually just fucking sit down and watch
television. Like everybody tape you
tape shit. That's just how it works.
Which is now if you watch like NFL Games,
they have this thing now where the game's
going on and all of a sudden the game
slides to the left and then this two
boxes and the advertising box is bigger
because they know that everybody's taping
games and they're blowing through it.
And advertisers somehow can
tell if someone fast forwarded
through and then they,
the NFL doesn't make as much money. So
now they're, they're running like this.
It's weird.
I think these two things,
he don't really have to
look at the commercial.
You can just sit there
looking at the game,
but then they're telling you about
fucking whatever at the same time. Yeah,
it's weird. That's gross. It's gross.
But is it, I mean, that's how, you know,
I make money off advertising. It's
like my, my thing and what's gross is,
is how your, uh, what, you know,
if you're dumping shit in the water
supply, if you got like all kinds of like,
you know, I mean I think they all have
some sort of labor fucking issues.
I would like, I would like to
be able to pay to not have that.
Like if I could Amazon one click,
I'm like,
well how much am I going
to give you for each game?
Well a don't have to see that.
Yeah, but they'll give you,
they will fit.
But what the advertisers would do is their
pockets are deeper and they're gonna,
they're gonna go,
they're gonna find like what's funny
is when the Internet started out,
all of a sudden you just,
you went from watching seeing all these
commercials to like nothing to now
seeing way more than you ever saw.
Like my,
the worst is when you watch an hour long
youtube video and then all of a sudden
it just stops and you know,
they try to make,
make a nice break and then you just watch
this and it annoys me. But I'm like,
well, I do advertise on my podcast
helps set about this. Can I get,
um,
you know, I don't know. When you see,
when you look at the line and you see
those little yellow lines on the youtube
video, we know that's where the
fucking ads are going to pop up. Oh No,
I didn't know that. Yeah. Isn't that
how it works? Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I
mean, look, advertising
is what it is. I mean,
it's either that or you do like a Patriot
type deal. We have people contribute.
Like Sam Harris does that,
right? It doesn't, you don't,
there's a million ways to do it,
but like I don't get mad at advertising
because like I said, a standup specials,
me advertising, then I'm going to
be out on the road and you say that,
but it's not, it's entertainment. It's
people that watch it. They can enjoy it.
Like no one's thinking about it that way.
It's a way also to do advertising
entertainment like way back.
Those less filling
tastes. Great. Bud lite.
Miller lite commercials were fucking
great. Funny. They were great.
And you wanted to see them and you love
them. Um, or at least I did a self. Yeah.
This ways.
There's ways to do everything.